um hi are you Earl Peele who do you want
to know I think I'm your son
Jordan Peele okay I see come on you're
here for a minute
close the door on the way in right I may
go ahead and seat the I'm explain
something to Kay I ain't your dad I'm
sorry to disappoint you but that's the
situation brother are you you see what's
happening we're doing the same thing I
always do this I always scratch the back
of my neck like this whenever I'm in an
uncomfortable situation scratch my name
yeah everybody spread stain it I breathe
in and out too man now everybody my kids
okay look at this that's a picture of me
when I was a baby that's my father
that ain't me look man look that dudes
afro look I got this going on man my
hair was gray he got black hair I mean
he handsome as hell but I ain't nobody's
daddy
I'm sorry just been looking for him
everywhere yeah
show you here just I got my own TV show
now I don't know I just I know that
wherever he is he he would be proud get
your own TV show huh yeah yeah yeah I'm
producing and acting hmm oh you oh you
producing and acting right okay yeah
that's my boy you looking at man we're
doing the same thing what is that holy
that's jeans right there man you cuz you
can't do that unless you're sharing mad
genes or somebody's got to be in your
DNA's oh you my son my baby boy thanks
for your time come back mister so muscle
man stop get off me when I first came to
your door you wouldn't even enough
okay okay you know what when I first
came in here stop that
when I first came in here you wouldn't
even acknowledge that I could possibly
be your son but now only after I tell
you that I have my own show on Comedy
Central whoa whoa whoa whoa
Comedy Central get the got in my house
you